new research from Drexel University
uncovered that a branch of army ants who
lived underground for 60 million years
moved to the surface 18 million years
ago and regrew the vision related parts
and increased the size of their brains
and researchers from Massachusetts
General Hospital are working on
regenerating functional heart muscle the
first steps in creating bioengineered
human hearts Vsauce Kevin here this is
mind blow meta skin can make things
invisible to radar the stretchable
material developed at Iowa State
University manipulates
electromagnetic waves using electric
rings filled with liquid metal the Rings
absorb radar frequency waves so an
object covered in this material would
essentially be impossible to detect
using radar in the 70 years since PE t
plastics have been in existence a
bacterium has already evolved to eat it
researchers in Japan discovered the
species attaching to PE T with tendril
like threads and using two enzymes to
break it down into its original
substances which aren't environmentally
harmful the goal now is to speed up the
process which currently takes about six
weeks to eat a thumbnail sized piece
computer vision is being used to find
the exact image you're looking for
taking a huge leap forward in 2012
computer vision is now used in
Facebook's facial recognition which is
featured in mind blow 80 as well as
Google's image CAPTCHA image searches
are typically hampered by keywords which
works okay if you want to find any old
picture of a blue bike but not great if
you need a very specific blue bike
shutter stocks new computer vision model
uses an images raw pixel data understand
what is contained within the image
enabling it to break the image down into
its dominant features that can be used
to find visually similar images as well
as perform a reverse image search of 70
million images all of this occurring in
double-digit milliseconds advances in
computer vision will aid automated
vehicles and robot sight researchers
have proven a technique that allows
kidneys to be donated to anyone
traditionally a compatible donor would
not only need the right blood
type but also the correct combination of
six antigens the chances of which are
one in 100,000
sadly around 4,500 people in the US
alone die annually waiting for that
match but with their desensitization
technique new antigens are regenerated
that are less likely to attack a newly
transplanted organ lessening the chance
for rejection and increasing the chance
of survival a potential game-changer for
kidney transplants Mima is a portable
glutton sensor by putting a sample of
the food in a disposable capsule the
sensors in the device tell you if
there's 20 parts per million or more of
gluten then display the results on the
front with an accuracy of 99.5 percent
and they're currently developing tests
to launch a similar device from peanuts
and dairy a new bionic fingertip allows
amputees to feel with their phantom hand
researchers at EPFL surgically implanted
electrodes into the nerve system of the
amputee which receive electrical signals
from the artificial fingertip a person
with an intact hand can also feel the
same sensation which helps accelerate
the research toward developing
prosthetics that can feel surfaces mind
blow 84 featured biobots
3d printed scaffolds connected by
engineered skeletal muscle tissue
controlled with electrical or optical
signals while they're now hoping to make
biobots with neurons that could sense
specific chemicals and tell the muscle
to move with potential applications like
environmental cleanup and clot busting
bots to treat cardiovascular disease my
mo 62 uncovered a real-world touchscreen
developed by Fujitsu laboratories
I used a projector and a webcam to allow
you to digitally manipulate objects on a
table
recently Sony's future lab unveiled its
own touch sensitive tabletop prototype
their proof-of-concept identifies a book
including text and illustrations which
become animated when you touch them it
also allows you to highlight text making
reading and learning an interactive
experience
finally Johns Hopkins Physics Laboratory
has developed an unmanned aerial vehicle
that can launch from underwater
Krakens can remain
at and launched from a depth of several
hundred feet without needing structural
metal parts or machine surfaces I'm
gonna leave you with a hexapod walking
on unstructured terrain and as always
thanks for watching and here it is the
greatest advance in television since
color television itself take the remote
unit from its handy storage space and
you're set for hours of pure pleasure
see all regular programs in crisp clear
black and white this selector button
changes channels clockwise while this
front window channel indicator lets you
know at a glance what channel you're
viewing yes here is the ultimate in
television a supreme achievement in
television engineering armchair
convenience luxurious styling a set
where the pride of ownership is truly
second only to the pleasure
you